[Music]
here you don't you don't need that
i mean i'm i'm fine with the code you
wrote but you could
just do that instead of unwrapping it
and then wrapping it again just
propagate it
this you don't need if you could just
say or self rate x equals 10.
your input is already a string slice so
this itself could be a string slice
instead of building a brand new string
and putting characters into it you could
take a slice of the input that would
avoid creating a new string
so you have this if
break break pattern you can i think you
can do
no you can't you can't merge those can
you i don't know if you can do
parentheses there can you do parentheses
can you do it like that
i don't know if you can do it like that
but if you could do it like that maybe
dude like that
and can't this be a while loop if you
can do that then this could be a while
loop right does does rust have a while
loop so you do while
why all this crap
there you go
so we checked after the stream and
apparently the while let and feature
doesn't really work
first you need to enable the
experimental let chains feature
but once you do that it accepts the
syntax but it doesn't like you using the
variables that you declare and let
outside the let's so
maybe in the future it'll work
right now this tip doesn't work at least
in general maybe in your case it'll work
i don't think you want to do that this
is making a copy of the token
so it's making a copy of all this crap
i'd make this a static reference
so it'll be a pointer to one of these
globals instead of copying all that junk
because you don't need a fresh copy of
this stuff and then this can be static
as well
you really shouldn't be using strings
for this stuff you're going to be doing
string comparisons and those are that's
like javascript level speed right there
you don't want to give rust a bad name
so enums enos would be a better option
but what i would probably do is not use
a hash set at all i would make a struct
that contains just a bunch of booleans
boolean for identifier bullying for
number you know hearing plus yeah et
cetera and then this would turn the
booleans on this would turn the booleans
off then there's no string compares
there's no hashing there's no
dynamic memory allocation or anything
like that maybe you wait and do bidder
operations probably not if you do u8 and
bid operations then if you think in the
assembly level a boolean is just an
address that you read and write to a
single instruction to manipulate the
boolean turn it on or off or read it a
bit operation i guess
it is a single instruction as well oh
okay so yeah i i kind of like your bit
idea in one operation you can set a lot
of bits that's that's a better idea than
a bunch of booleans
do you have tests for this
where's your tests i said the bottom
evaluator
no tests this is like the easiest thing
in the world to test two plus two is
equal to four
right you'd bang out so many tests for
this thing i mean writing error tests
are a bit more annoying it's in your
main
no that's that's not a test this is a
test program that you mainly run and you
mainly verify the results but there's
nothing saying that this
equals whatever it's supposed to be
there's nothing checking that for you so
when you run this program it'll print
out 18 but you're like is that the right
answer i don't know if you write a test
script that just checks a bazillion
different combinations then you don't
gotta second-guess yourself it
definitely deserves some tests these
kinds of things super easy to test with
automated tests you just bang out like
50 tests super easy the test would be
short two plus two should equal four
right
oh that was all an operator
jesus christ what i would do in an ideal
world i would split this up i would put
all this code to handle operator i would
make that in a function and if i put it
in a function i probably need to give it
all these variables so instead of giving
all of these variables i would make a
struct for to hold all these things so
i'd make a struct for all this then add
some functions on that struct like parts
operator and maybe instead of continue
or
whatever or break you might do a return
might be easier to follow and be less
indentation for sure because like
you're pretty deep here it's worse than
yak output
if you spend some time on it i think you
can improve the code it's just like you
just gotta put in the effort
this is kind of repeated over and over
again it's always evaluator error and
then some message you could make a
function for that to make it a one-liner
just to like compress the code make it
easier to skim through
assignment operator if you don't have it
inserted
when would this ever be true i don't
think this code would ever run i think
it would have to exist because that's
the whole point of this code up here
make sure it exists if you refer to it
so i would turn this into an assertion
assert that a key definitely exists same
here
same there gotta look how to assert
assert is
just
insert
i don't know two plus two equals four
and if it doesn't happen your program
crashes so it serves as documentation
you can make a
get variable function that returns an
option of a ref to variable value you
could do that
and then you would have a fun get
variable myself
much nicer oh you need the
token
identifier
[Music]
why'd you write it like this that could
be
that could be written like that right
whoa
you got an equals if here i would say
it's probably better to write this using
match i would prefer to see match here
so match
number no match self values pop
so if it's some number
number
otherwise
that
it just feels more familiar to me anyway
your style's fine or
there's um
okay or yeah you can do that so this be
okay or
this error
question mark it's even fancier so that
says do the pop if if the pop succeeded
if you got some just wrap it in okay it
did succeed give an error actually i
don't
need that then if you got the error
return so it's a shorter code by a
little bit you see i don't come up with
the best idea of the first time round i
think you could do the same thing here
you got the same pattern here
so overall it looks good it makes sense
structured how i would expect a parser
an evaluator to be structured a lot of
duplicate code lots of indents yeah i'm
sure you're able to factor a lot of that
out monkey toilet ladder huh
good name
good name
you got better tips than me put a
comment down below